well i think you know we've all been
watching those really
just appalling scenes this is terrible
absolutely terrible in terms of the
violence
um the activities that we've seen
we've just seen you know confidence in
democracy being shattered quite frankly
and there's no justification
for the level of violence full stop that
was
on show and has been on display and
people have been assaulted people have
died
we've also seen you know law enforcement
officers being assaulted too
and it's really sad it's tragic to see
actually on the basis that you know
america has always been a fantastic
beacon of democracy
liberty freedom um you know just great
values of tolerance decency and
democracy
so no question absolutely no question at
all just
really terrible scenes i i will
note however home secretary as indeed
others will the two words that didn't
pass your lips there were
donald and trump what will it take
for a senior politician in the british
government like yourself
to condemn the actions of this man well
i think i think
absolutely the violence you know should
stop and he should he should absolutely
um condemn everything that has taken
place um you know there's no question
about that at all
someone was shot people have died um
this is terrible
terrible beyond words quite frankly and
there is no justification for it the
reason i'm pushing on this is because
it has been conceded by people on both
sides of the political divide
in the united states incredibly senior
figures on the republican side as well
that the president of the united states
donald trump is complicit in what we saw
on capitol hill yesterday on that basis
i think what people may want to hear
from a very senior politician like
yourself
is a statement a bold statement
condemning the involvement
of donald trump and what happened
yesterday well i think first of all
i mean he made a statement yesterday and
it did very little to de-escalate the
situation
so there is no question first of all
there's no justification
you know words of provocation are
completely wrong
and quite frankly every aspect of the
violence and the activities that took
place
should be condemned that is absolutely
right and you know
quite frankly we've we've seen you know
we've heard from
the president-elect we've seen just
shattering absolutely shattering
pictures
um coming out from from washington
and as i've said america is a beacon of
democracy and freedom
and quite frankly it's right now um that
they
move on they get on with an orderly
transition
and that violence there's no
justification for it whatsoever it has
to stop
the democratic minority leader in the
senate uh chuck schumer described the
45th president of the united states as
its worst
do you agree with that well look it's i
i'm
you know we're not going to i'm not
going to get into um you know comments
of that nature the fact of the matter is
there's been no justification for what
has happened
at all and that violence is completely
unacceptable
and on that basis alone people have died
and
you know there is transition in america
at the end of elections have always been
smooth
you know the world looks to america for
peaceful transitions and it's important
now that they
absolutely get on um get on with that
process of transition and moving their
country forward
i'm going to give the opportunity just
one last time because obviously we do
need to talk about covert 19 and indeed
enforcement of the new regulations but i
want to give you the opportunity one
more time
to condemn the involvement of donald
trump and what happened yesterday
condemn the man himself his lack uh of
an
order to of a timely order
for people to acting in his name to
leave the capitol building
uh for him sitting on the sidelines once
again
in the situation which you know did
pretty predictably
turn violent very quickly well i have
said he should you know he should
absolutely condemn the situation condemn
the violence
um but his words also did very little to
de-escalate the situation yesterday
um you know so quite frankly what we
have seen is absolutely appalling
there's no justification for it
whatsoever
i mean you've seen all your viewers have
absolutely seen the most appalling and
shocking scenes
at the heart of democracy in the united
states of america
and that violence should be condemned it
should be condemned by donald trump as
well
absolutely um but at the same time right
now
you know america has to move on you know
they've had their election
and they've had their process they've
had their process and quite frankly they
do now need to move on
um but what we have seen is absolutely
appalling and terrible there is no
justification for it whatsoever